2006 buschbrände vor allem im südosten
des landes gibt 176 todesopfer stopp
jeden tag hören wir von
ungerechtigkeiten katastrophen morden
skandalen oder diktatur schon 2016 wurde
vom schlimmsten jahr aller zeiten
gesprochen
bis 2017 kam danach wurde 2018 als
schlimmstes jahr aller zeiten für den
finanzmarkt bezeichnet und dann kam 2009
10 das schlimmste jahr für unsere
privatsphäre
das alles wirft ein ziemlich dunkles
licht auf das jetzt kommende jahr 2020
aber diese headlines gab es nicht für
2012 2005 oder 1992 war früher also
wirklich alles besser
nein die menschheit macht jeden tag
immense fortschritte menschenrechte
gesundheit ernährung tatsächlich ging es
uns in vielerlei hinsicht noch nie so
gut wie jetzt gerade deswegen schauen
wir uns heute sechs bereiche an in denen
früher nicht alles besser war und jetzt
für euch warum wir vielleicht eure
nachrichten konsum überdenken sollte
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
aufgewachsen und abonniert gerne den
kanal wenn ihr kein neues video
verpassen wollte
in wien
im team gewonnen
platz vor dem tor wird in besitz
genommen
vom deutschen post
die tms 64
im jahr
wir schaffen
[Applaus]
beginnen wir mit einer unserer
wichtigsten und größten errungenschaften
seit 1990 haben bessere hygiene und
ernährung maßnahmen die leben von 120
millionen kindern gerettet
noch vor 30 jahren sind 17 prozent aller
kinder in afrika vor dem fünften
lebensjahr verstorben stand 2015 konnte
man diese zahl halbieren und die tendenz
sind weiterhin haupttodesursache war
hier die höhe
dank luckow so präparaten können mit
geringem aufwand aber kranke kinder
lebensnotwendigen mineralien um
flüssigkeiten bekommen dank unseres
enormen fortschritts können kinder aber
nicht nur häufiger überleben sondern
auch länger kinder bleiben während der
industrialisierung war es normal für ein
kind ab dem achten lebensjahr zu
arbeiten für ein niedriges gehalt und
unter gefährlichen und dreckigen
bedingungen arbeiteten kinder bis zu 12
stunden am tag ohne pause aber seit
jahrzehnten geht der anteil von
arbeitenden kindern nach unten
das hat viele gründe zum beispiel die
schulpflicht bis zum 18 lebensjahr
härtere gesetze und kontrollen und all
das hat in der vergangenheit dazu
geführt dass kinderarbeit eingedämmt
wird
und es wird weiter kontinuierlich an
besseren methoden gearbeitet stand 2020
hat die welt noch nie so viel akzeptanz
für gleichgeschlechtliche ehen und
partnerschaften gezeigt und das obwohl
homosexualität in deutschland bis 1994
strafbar war und die ehe für alle erst
2017 legal ist
mittlerweile haben weltweit 26 länder
die gleichgeschlechtliche ehe
legalisiert 39 länder zeigen den
umfragen eine breite akzeptanz von
gleichgeschlechtlichen partnerschaften
zusätzlich hinterfragen wir stereotypen
und sprache um diskriminierung auf basis
von geschlecht hautfarbe oder religion
zu bekämpfen
weltweit genießen seit 1946 wesentlich
mehr menschen menschenrechte
natürlich ist es bei vielen dieser
themen noch ein langer weg bis
gerechtigkeit einkehrt trotzdem kann man
vor allem in der westlichen welt einen
deutlichen aufwärtstrend beobachten
wollt ihr euch über etwas informieren
dann google tier ist wahrscheinlich gut
vielleicht auf wikipedia oder schaut
hier sogar mal auf youtube vorbei ihr
habt also zu jedem zeitpunkt zugriff auf
millionen von medien und könnt euch
selbstständig weiterbilden
das internet bietet uns einen enormen
vorteil den wir im alltag wahrscheinlich
für selbstverständlich halten die
wissenschaft hat aber gezeigt dass
studenten mit internetzugriff weitaus
bessere leistungen bringen
andere studien zeigten dass uns das
internet tatsächlich gesünder macht wir
haben zugang zu informationen und sind
in der lage nach lösungen und ärzten zu
googeln als ich geboren wurde haben
gerade mal 44 millionen menschen
weltweit internet zugriff gehabt
mittlerweile sind es 3,4 milliarden pro
stunde gibt es mehr als 27.000 neue
internetnutzer
das sind also seit beginn dieses videos
ungefähr 2000 neue leute die jetzt
internet haben die vor ort viereinhalb
fünf minuten noch kein internet haben
laut dem oxford institute stehen die
größten änderungen durch das internet
tatsächlich noch bevor
aber auch jetzt schon macht das internet
die welt ein stück besser vor allem für
die sexuelle unabhängigkeit von frauen
bietet das internet enorme vorteile als
erlaubt das selbstständige informieren
über zb verhütung oder abtreibungen aber
auch für verfolgte und unterdrückte
menschen wie journalisten in china oder
russland bieten das world wide web und
das dark knight ein sprachrohr und die
möglichkeit nach hilfe zu rufen
zusätzlich ermöglicht das schnelle
teilen von inhalten das theoretisch kein
verbrechen ungesehen bleibt bei den
protesten in hongkong war es
beispielsweise möglich völkerrechts
verbrechen mit der welt zu teilen
wie sehr uns das internet nach vorne
bringt hängt natürlich stark davon ab ob
es reguliert wird
starke zensur des internets wie zum
beispiel in china verhindert freie
meinungsäußerung und bildung mangelnder
zugriff hängt aber auch oft mit
fehlender infrastruktur oder armut
zusammen aber allein seit gestern ist
die zahl der menschen die in extremer
armut leben um 192.000 gesunken
ich sag es gerne noch mal seit gestern
leben 192.000 menschen nicht mehr in
extremer armut
das könnte eigentlich jeden tag in den
nachrichten kommen sollte man die medien
dafür kritisieren dass sie es nicht
jeden tag bringen
dazu später mehr unter extremer armut
lebt man nach internationalem standard
wenn man weniger als einen dollar um 90
cent am tag vergibt heute lebt das erste
drittel der weltbevölkerung mit mehr als
zehn dollar am tag
eine prognose des oxford institutes
rechne mit 900 millionen menschen die
mindestens zehn jahren über 10 dollar am
tag verdienen werden
ein deutlicher aufwärtstrend neben armut
geht auch der welthunger deutlich zurück
in weiten teilen afrikas hat sich in den
letzten 15 jahren hungersnot fast
halbiert in brasilien und china hat sich
diese zahl sogar noch weiter reduziert
und das ist alles nur die spitze des
eisbergs die weltweiten mordraten sinken
es wird weniger waffenfähiges uran
angereichert mehr kinder haben zugang zu
bildung und gehen länger zur schule als
noch vor zehn jahren
wir arbeiten weniger haben mehr freizeit
als noch vor hundert jahren und
zusätzlich wachsen wird wortwörtlich
seit mehr als 200 jahren werden menschen
immer größer
das ist zurückzuführen auf bessere
ernährung und lebensstandards die
lebenserwartung steigt dank besserer
medizin in europa leben wir im vergleich
zu 1990 sechs jahre länger
wir leben in einer zeit von sehr großen
veränderungen
leider bleiben trotzdem viele schlechte
entwicklungen bestehen es besitzen auch
noch 2020 ein prozent der
weltbevölkerung mehr geld als die
unteren 50 prozent der klimawandel
könnte unseren planeten unbewohnbar
machen und ein rechtsruck in der
westlichen welt attackiert die
demokratie depression und angst ist auf
einem allzeithoch genau wie die
selbstmordrate das sind wichtige themen
und es wird viel darüber berichtet
zu viel immerhin sorgen viele dieser
schlechten nachrichten für ebendiese
depressionen ängste und selbstmorde
außerdem steht hinter unnötiger
dramatisierung und klickt die motivation
klicks und verkäufe zu generieren
die bild würde sich halt nicht
sonderlich gut verkaufen wenn darauf
stehen würde heute alles gut wie viele
von euch checke ich jeden tag die
nachrichten alles was mir dort entgeht
bekomme ich dann durch social media mit
bei mir ist das meistens tritt dank
digitalisierung bin ich also rund um die
uhr informiert
was aber wenn dieser ständigen newsflash
zur last wird können wir medien für ein
negatives weltbild verantwortlich machen
ich glaube nicht schlimme dinge
passieren jeden tag und es ist gut und
vor allem wichtig darüber informiert zu
sein
es ist wichtig dass wir über die
proteste in hongkong die waldbrände in
australien oder die
menschenrechtsverletzungen in katar
informiert werden
die besten demokratischen bürgerinnen
und bürger sind die die über den status
quo und die probleme in ihrem land und
der welt bescheid wissen und so können
wir dann für diese lösungen wählen gehen
fakt ist letztendlich immer mehr
menschen auf der welt geht es besser und
zwar gerade weil wir über die probleme
der menschen bescheid wissen
wenn wir also weiterhin als menschheit
besser werden wollen dann müssen wir die
probleme dieser welt kennen was
natürlich nicht heißt dass man die
nachrichten nicht auch mal auslassen
kann josef der changement hat das in
seinem neuesten selbstexperiment gemacht
sieben tage ohne nachrichten ich habe
inzwischen durch besucht um mal gesehen
wie er so lebt ohne nachrichten das
video von ihm könnt ihr euch jetzt
angucken ist gerade online gegangen und
ich habe tatsächlich auch einen kleinen
partner drin und erzähle euch wie sich
schlechte nachrichten auf den körper
auswirken
wir sehen uns also da drüben viel spaß
dabei ansonsten vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig patrick